d'ailleurs si formidable c'est
formidable de quelques succès six idées
c'est formidable si vous êtes gentils
mélange l'honneur et citoyen c'est un
triomphe d'un triomphe et puis on peut
dire que vous avez tapé dans le mille 1
va pas vivre 900 noms mais il parle
direct et puis on va j'ai vu un vous
avez vos affiches sur tous les murs de
paris comme sale je remercie mon rang
est alors qu'est ce que vous devez être
fiers quand même bien sûr que ça fait
plaisir parce que si je vous disais le
contraire moi je suis un vrai hypocrite
on croirait que bien alors je me
rappelle est dictée changement avec les
débuts je me rappelle les débuts d'ee
vous avez vous passion numéro un dans un
music hall ce travail là bas nous étions
le vétéran je me rappelle même vous
arriviez au métro vous arrivions vous
vous prenez le métro arrive au théâtre
même si ce n'était pas mon premier vrai
citons deuxième et avait pas troisième
aulas je me rappelle vous étiez mal
fagotée empoté mal foutu
c'est normal c'était mes débuts c'était
début et maintenant
et maintenant si la gloire vous avez des
rhumatismes quoi mais ça c'est résoudre
il a donc de le docteur titre et un fort
effet alors maintenant je parle pas vous
parler des voyages des tournées portait
même à l'étranger et ailleurs et puis on
entend on entend vos chansons à la radio
j'entends vos chances à la radio
l'auvergnat la valse à mille des
flamandes et vous on peut dire que vous
vous en avez fait du chemin
monsieur monsieur
monsieur c'est moment déjà or même on
est vraiment peu de choses